[Music]
agnes considers herself one of the first
ones here most people think she's an
insufferable snob i understand her
having played her now all these months
there's a big story line in the arrival
of the russell family who are building a
mansion across the street from my town
house and when my late husband bought
this it was rural central park was just
countryside she doesn't know the
russells she can't stand what they're
about it's all manipulation and
ostentation and it's everything that i
abhor judging by your aunt's face it'll
be a while before you see me here again
i give marion a hard time
she's my brother's daughter and i know
what my brother was like and it led to
his ruin you lived or died by your
reputation i feel that agnes has her
best interests in mine i really do i
know more about these things than you
give me credit for my brother was
supposed to manage the estate but he
squandered it i really had to step up
and be the big sister money isn't
everything you say that to me after the
sacrifice i made to save your skin there
is undercurrent of resentments i'm very
grateful so you should be
i can see rather quickly that peggy is
extremely smart if you're interested i
would like to hire you as my secretary
that does interest me i can see that
peggy's journey is a lot harder than my
nieces is going to be agnes has had a
tough life she respects anybody who
still is going to make something of
herself life has taught me one thing
miss scott
if you don't want to be disappointed
only help those who help themselves
that's the woman you see at the
beginning of the series is a woman who's
just had to
really make it on her own i love keying
into her extraordinary strength and
certitude
aydah is an unmarried lady what was
called at that time a spinster an old
maid
she is the sister of agnes who is a
wealthy widow and she is the aunt of
marion who is much to aida's delight
coming to live with her two aunts in new
york city this is miss marion brooke our
late brother's daughter for ada who
doesn't have any children of her own
here is a chance to be a mother of sorts
all we both want is your happiness
you may disagree with us
but that is all we want
across the street are the russells who
are the new money and their house is
amazing their carriage is amazing their
footman's outfits are amazing it's a
palace and mr and mrs russell are
industrialists and new money and it's a
fight between
the old new york and new new york my
mother your grandmother was a livingston
of livingston manor they ruled justly
until the new people invaded it's not
quite as simple as that yes it is agnes
disapproves of them greatly this is just
like the devil has moved in across the
street
ada isn't so sure she knows she
shouldn't be interested in them but she
can't help but
creep over to the window and look out
the blinds as they move into their new
home with all their finery christmases
chamberlain and know them why don't we
just go outside and roll in the gutter
that will save time remember agnes
charity is the order of the day agnes is
really afraid of change and ada is eager
for it she's at this moment in her life
when things have just been the same for
a really long time and there's nothing
happening and now
things are afoot and afoot not just in
the world and not just in new york but
within her own family and
on her own street
marion sees the world as full of
brightness and what is so
cool about marion
is her strength of character
[Music]
we meet marion when she's lost
everything she's lost her home she's
lost her father she's lost most of her
possessions
you will have somewhere in the region of
30
and she comes to new york she's very
vulnerable and doesn't have any footing
anymore except for her aunts and she's
heard a lot of bad things about agnes
you are my niece
and you belong to old new york agnes
immediately tells her that she has to
come out of mourning you will go
tomorrow with ada to my dressmaker and
no black
but i'm in mourning people here won't
know that henry died that's the first
instance where i really butt heads with
her she can be so like him at times she
speaks and i hear henry's voice
challenging everything just as he did
and look how that turned out
well i like her strong views
i like her energy
ada is more understanding of me
we also have a bond over my father you
told me antagonist hated my father
because he sold our family house do you
feel the same agnes has always carried
the weight of the world on her shoulders
henry used to tease me and make me laugh
so no
i don't feel the same way peggy and
marion's relationship is really
interesting i hope one day to write a
novel
i envy you
i'm not like you i don't have any
burning talent yearning to be free i
just want to be busy to be needed
peggy and marion's relationship grows
from a transactional moment
into a more meaningful relationship
where marian looks up to peggy and is
inspired by peggy it ends up growing
into even more than that why don't you
look in
antagonists would have a fit i could
wait downstairs to make sure you can get
back in
my fellow conspirator
[Music]
something i think is so interesting
about peggy's character is she's the one
woman we kind of get to see in the
professional class
[Music]
there was a newer class that was
developing during that time what it
meant to not be in the service industry
or to be an inherited wealth aristocrat
but to be a lawyer a writer an architect
we see these different things i do know
you've taken a chance on me mrs van ren
and i appreciate it
life has taught me one thing miss scott
if you don't want to be disappointed
only help those who help themselves
she runs into every kind of obstacle
that you would face as someone who has
the audacity to dream of being a writer
as a black woman in that time what other
changes must i make to be published
your name is fine but your race would
have to remain concealed it's the best
arrangement i can offer there are at
least two white men sitting in a bar
around the corner drinking away their
sorrows because i turned them down
they kill to be in your position
[Music]
but they'd never be in my position
we get to see peggy have these
interesting moments downstairs in the
basement when peggy is with the service
staff of that household and
you're able to see the assumption that
is made by all of them that peggy must
be
poor peggy must not have access to these
certain kinds of things have you been
working with mrs van roy yes i suppose
you think that makes you a sort of
secretary she is a secretary and not a
sort of anything which puts her above
you in the pecking order miss armstrong
like if it were the 1880s this would
have been my story the proximity that i
walked today felt very similar to the
proximity that she was walking and it
fell off the page to me i know what
she's
carrying you're a new yorker now
we both are
and for a new yorker anything is
possible
i think one of the most challenging
aspects of
playing oscar has been keeping this
moustache exactly the same shape for
over a year
oscar has definitely learned
the value of a good verbal laceration
from his mother stop talking to yourself
and ring the bell i'm going up to change
i doubt it
i'd say you will come down again without
having changed at all in a world where
almost everyone tiptoes around agnes
terrified of courting her displeasure
oscar is basically the only character
who is fearless i think fundamentally
they're very close which is why she
endures this agnes views new york elite
society as a small group of people with
notable genealogy and that's the way she
would like it to remain oscar i think
can see this new money is going to have
greater influence and he wants to be a
part of it i think we should know the
russell family i would go further and
say i think it is mad that we don't
money is of
primordial importance to oscar he is
very much on the hunt for an heiress he
is independently wealthy himself he will
one day inherit the whole brooks
household but he sees wealth a whole new
magnitude and he has an insatiable
hunger for the lifestyle that that will
support must have more money i love all
the minutiae of etiquette and the
behavioral codes i've tried to break as
many of those rules as possible in every
scene because i play a character who has
a heartier reverence for those rules
especially when he's in the brooks
household i think he's aware that this
kind of charm is a commodity in polite
new york society verbal playfulness has
a kind of currency to it handsome young
men who talk are always useful that's
what my mother says and a girl should
always listen to her mother oscar kind
of goes through life considering it a
game where you can make up your own
rules this is a world where most
characters are very bound by social
conduct and the codes of behavior and
it's quite fun to play a part who is
happy to break those rules he'd much
rather be happy than good
tom rights is a young confident
hard-working attorney from doylestown
pennsylvania
[Music]
in episode one we meet him and marion
brooke and i think at the start it's a
professional relationship but he quickly
becomes quite charmed by her being put
in that position as her attorney and
trying to help her financially get back
on her feet he's the one who pushes her
to move to new york to have a safety net
and to be with her aunts i'm sorry
you're going miss brooke
but you're glad i will be taken care of
and good luck on your travels
i was interested to play a young guy who
was trying to find his way in a world
that he didn't quite know but do it with
you know a chin up and a hard working
attitude i think there are clear rules
in that society at that point in time
for sure he's walking into a world that
has old ways that are set and he's not
particularly accepted off the bat we
only receive the old people in this
house nevertheless he has to work quite
hard to ingratiate himself i guess for
lack of a better word into that society
there's a clear difference between the
old money and the new money not that he
comes from either i think he comes from
no money really and that's what's so
interesting about him is that he has a
wonderful arc really starting from
humble beginnings
and through hard work he manages to
climb that ladder new york has plenty to
offer the new arrival but what would i
have to offer new york it's just a joy
to come to work and to work on these
characters and in this world there's so
much depth to everything i wish i
understood what brings you to new york
simple i want to be here and that's
enough of a reason of course it is i see
what i really want i take it if i can
one of the interesting aspects i think
of households with armies of servants
you had to rely on their discretion and
i think banister rather prides himself
on his discretion
welcome to east 61st street miss marion
and my name is banister and this is van
riden's butler bannister the butler is
the
backbone
of the brookhouse which is owned by mrs
van reine and uh her sister ada mrs van
ryne makes it quite clear who is the
boss of the house and i'm in command of
staff i wonder if they'll try to set him
up with miss marion he wants an heiress
the richest he can find and miss marion
hasn't a penny to her name if you finish
demolishing the characters of every
member of this family john and i will
serve luncheon
we have a fairly compact staff i think
somehow we keep the house running very
efficiently thanks to my
steady gaze
come on john
look lively i think perhaps he has a
self-image of being the general
authority and senior figure of the staff
i think his natural britishness makes
him come across occasionally is rather
cold and chilly but that helps with his
authority i don't want trouble in the
house and while she may not want to
cause she may be impossible i repeat it
is not for us to have an opinion
certainly not that one what i found very
extraordinary is the people with money
how uncomfortable their lives
nonetheless were from the way they
dressed from the formality of their
behavior the extraordinary social
rituals they had to endure it was
routine that was how it was done
it does seem a terrible chore
[Music]
you